that movie took a year off my life but
like in a good way like it was fun
but i'm exhausted
today we're here to watch a movie about
heights my biggest fear i don't like
heights i don't like being high anywhere
a theme park i just can't do it i don't
like roller coasters hell nah i would
never go rock climbing bungee jumping no
not me son i'll wait for you down on the
ground so i was invited by buzzfeed to
come to lionsgate to watch an exclusive
screening of fall when i watch movies i
i feel like i'm part of that movie
i feel like i could go one of two ways
one i'm like fine because it's somebody
else and not me or
i'm not actually a screamer but i jump
they gave me this little watchy very
cute and it is going to track my heart
rate i'm going into this film
optimistically
but i can't promise you i won't cry
let's do this i'm so excited to be here
oh oh oh oh oh you
oh my god
that's right son
okay ready for this roll the tape
oh it started we're gonna start watching
this movie how y'all feel a little
scared
you're just the heights
do people do this for fun
not that he look like my cousins
[Music]
there goes my dominican brother
that escalated so quickly who told him
to put his hand in that hole
nobody
see i would be scared at that height
[Music]
go back down you okay no no no
you're doing great
come on there's a reason there's fear
inside of you it's saying don't do it oh
yeah yeah
oh my god what is the ladder fall oh
[Applause]
[Music]
my jaw literally has never dropped more
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
what the [ __ ]
oh
my
god
literally i don't know that i've ever
reacted that hard
no that's like took a year off my life
wow
my body before calm collected excited my
body after limp shaky anxious sometimes
the music you you feel like okay she's
gonna overcome this and sometimes the
music is like they're gonna die you
can't pay me anything to climb up that
tower but a billion dollars there's
nothing to a dead person
i knew this was going to be tough but
this was something else the most
traumatizing scene was the one
where
and it's
come out oh my god trying to like
i was like oh my god i just that was the
moment i turned away see i'm 70 right
now i think my highest was like 120. my
heart rate got over 100 for sure
multiple times i would not want to watch
that alone i wanted to hold on to some
videos like someone to keep me safe if
you have a fear of heights
honestly just bring friends you want to
hear the audience going woo yo no that
just did it that's the perfect movie to
take a date trust me
trust me check out fall only in theaters
august 12.